[Musik]
ausländische
Blasphemie und Götzendienst, okay, es ist nicht
schön, schau es dir
nicht an.
Mansion ist
ein Bonuspräsident und er ist so
lächerlich billig, weißt du, und er ist
auch so machtlos wie dein König, also warum
nimmst du ihn nicht, denn niemand würde
kommen  Hier, um unseren Premierminister zu sehen. Ja
ja, das würden sie nicht, wissen Sie, niemand kümmert sich darum,
nein,
kein Leben lang. Ist es nicht billiger, wenn der Wind
sagt, dass sie in den nächsten Saisons
der Krone spielen? Ich bin sicher, das wäre ja, ähm,
nein, schon wieder sie  Sie sind nicht sie selbst,
obwohl sie sich nicht selbst repräsentieren. Sie
repräsentieren die gesamte Nation. Der
König repräsentiert alles, was
an Großbritannien und am Commonwealth gut ist.
Verstehe ich das richtig? Monarchie ist
eine gute Sache, aber die EU war
für Sie nicht demokratisch genug
Die EU ist ein völlig anderes Thema.
Unser Bonuspräsident ist so langweilig, dass Sie
ihn sehen wollen. Ich zeige es Ihnen. Okay,
ja, vielleicht, was
denken Sie? Ich
bin mir nicht sicher. Ja, ich bin nicht sicher,
ich bin hier.
Wow
[Applaus]
250 Millionen  Das heißt, und wer bezahlt
die 250 Millionen? Mit 250 kann man viel machen.
Du weißt
genau, in Deutschland kann man eine Menge davon kaufen.
So retten wir die Erde und Robert
Habeck, du bist so gemein, du bist gemeiner als
Megan  Das ist es, Megan, ja, na ja,
sie ist genauso schlecht wie alle anderen bei ihrem
Besuch, sie hat sich darauf eingelassen, also ratet mal,
was sie am Ende des Tages verdient,
ja,
fremd
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Genau Gott schütze den König
häufig und fürchten Jeff Bezos vor ihren Welpen